i think he said bravery yeah
handsomeness
style style talent talent
overwhelming talent um zag insurance
second insurance for now as long as i
can keep it you will
but um for the bravery thing and it's
really i mean a lot of people have
reached out and saying you know
you're an inspiration and that's really
lovely in fact i've got this i'm going
to show off my my fancy shirt i just
my daughter designed this broken i love
it
so we were selling these to a company
called stands to help raise money for
the stroke association to bring
awareness to stroke survival
stroke prevention and rehab but um
part of the broken thing i just want to
it's not a brand new idea but
you can think about how you can bend a
stick or tree branch to a certain point
until
it breaks i'm just gonna be like i'm not
broken yet
i'm unbroken and so through this and
meeting other stroke survivors you get a
lot of really lovely interaction with
people saying i'm it's
inspirational but i really do want to
address the burglary part
of early on to me going yeah i'm fine
i'm fine i'm fine i'm not gonna wallow
in there i'm not gonna sit and well i'm
not gonna have a pity party in the
corner
where that's one thing i mean mourning
your physical
health or mental health or emotional
health
you know a lot of ways to feel like
maybe i haven't really been dealt with
it
so i haven't really delved into what i
can't do i try really trying to focus on
what i can do rather what i can do
but i don't know how brave it is but um
where i haven't really sat in it too
much because i'm almost afraid my wife
had to talk to this little bit
i'm almost afraid if i do get there if i
do go to that point i'll get really
angry and
maybe won't be able to recover from that
so my i've just been sort of stiff upper
lip
but again i don't know if that's the
healthiest way to go
well i i it's good analysis and really
delve into it
yeah because it amazes me i you know i
think gosh how many breakdowns would i
have had within the first
you know month like god i love it oh
like yeah
you know just like you know what i i'm
sure and it's just like
you know everyone has different ways of
dealing with it but you know
it's amazing i think you know what i
gather
you know briefly what we talked about in
the beginning just this upbringing and
this love and then
you think about your family and
suffering through the depression you've
got these two wonderful girls you've got
this wife and you've been so lucky
somehow in your mind you've been sort of
programmed
inadvertently or whatever that you know
that's why you were able to put things
in perspective like
you did the way you handled is the way
that
that's of course how tim is going to
handle it
now i think a big part of it also is i
was always an optimist
i mean i was always saying what's on the
other side of the hill kind of guy i
mean
i think you got to be to be an actor
because you come into this town you're
like i'm going to try to do this thing
that
they give you the numbers like if you
really let listen to the numbers
no one would ever really try this it's
like of course of course nobody's going
to work
nobody's going to succeed so because
i've always been yeah let's give it a
shot let's see what's over there let's
keep going looking forward and i've
always been a um
it could always be worse kind of guy i
mean i
i have a friend with a terminal disease
so it's like what am i gonna see her
[ __ ] i'm gonna cry because i can't walk
i can't run or hike
like i used to so it's like you know you
really just i have to look around
i've got plenty of friends plenty of
friends with ms who are having really
difficult times so i know a lot of
people that are in much worse
situations than me and i think just
having the
perspective of positivity has always
been has helped me kind of
look at things differently now when i'm
in the situation yeah
and knowing you're loved by the way
knowing the overwhelming amount of love
that you you've been given that's
it's massive i think that has to be such
a big part of just like so many people
are rooting for you and like the fans
and the psychos and the
i mean it's just like i could tell in
having that
being loved that much i mean being loved
is important alone but being loved that
much
has got to give you the strength or help
with the strength to get through things
it really does i mean it absolutely does
knowing that there's people out there
who give a [ __ ] of how i'm doing that
day
and um through this day said i want to
go to the clinic
like i'm tired i'm [ __ ] this my leg
hurts
but i think of my friends who who are
rooting for me
and the people the different phantoms
out there who are just so pulling for me
and reaching out in various ways i was
like i gotta get up off my ass gotta go
do this
because in a way i i don't want to let
them down i would like my kids i don't
wanna let myself down my wife down